you know this riff it's the song
American woman originally created by
this guy my name is Randy Bachman
I'm with in the band I guess who it was
a big hit in the 60s and became one of
the most iconic anti-war songs of the
Vietnam era when you look back in time
and go wow that absolutely changed our
life that didn't change our life have
changed everybody's life had changed the
world had changed radio but here's the
thing that song that changed radio it
wasn't born in some recording studio but
by accident live onstage in a Canadian
curling arena so it's a cold February
day in North Dakota Randy and the rest
of the guests who just crossed the
Canadian border with the intention of
playing a show down in Texas while
filling up their truck at a local gas
station a u.s. Border Patrol officer was
calling out to them hip saying hey boy
you got to go into that building over
there boy he got going to do something
and it was some sort of service building
I'm not sure what he was saying because
of their green cards the officer was
telling them to enter the Selective
Service building to be drafted and sent
to Vietnam so we were like terribly
frightened we got into her car drove a
couple hundred miles back to Canada and
we're in Canada without a gig so Randy
made a call to a booking agency and
because of a last-minute cancellation he
was able to find a gig at a curling
arena in water and we we were playing a
three-hour dance and in the middle of
one song I broke a string and their lead
singer Burton Cummings said well Randy's
broken a string we don't have spirit are
he's going to change the string so we're
going to take a break so everybody was
kind of sitting around talking so I had
to get that guitar in tune so as I was
onstage playing that ecord
I play an E chord a D chord D chord and
a metal accord with the strings ringing
and suddenly I get dun dun Duda that
event of them said is evident
oh my god I don't want to forget this
rich I stand up and I start playing and
I turn my guitar I'm playing it louder
and I look into the audience and came
running up was Burton Cummings finally I
yelled up sing something seeing anything
first thing he sang was
America
and lass
we need a songwriter you hope for
inspiration from somewhere you don't
know where it's going to come from you
don't know a miniscule or how gigantic
that little moment is going to be take
that little inspiration and put some dry
fuel on it some dry paper and see if you
can build a bonfire you never really
know where it's going to come from you
never know how far it is going to go
where it's going to take you